hallo leute und willkommen
so lockt mit tag in meiner vorstellung
bar sowie geiler ich habe heute schon
wie ich bin heute schon um 630
aufgewacht ein neues video zu schneiden
die haarbüschel wieder stunden dran
gebracht es lag oder definitiv daran
dass irgendwie ständig eingeschlafen bin
aber zwei babys besser
aaron rome ist ja irgendwie auch wieso
ich weiß es nicht ich kann es nicht
beschreiben
kelly ist auf dem weg hierher aus
stuttgart ich glaube sie sollte jede
sekunde eintreffen
ich bin gespannt auf ihre reaktion auf
das schlafzimmer und ganz besonders
fensters dicker ja für so nen ganzen
drehtag muss man sich jetzt schöne
schminken die eu benutzen nicht
vergessen und ich hoffe wir gehen
irgendwas leckeres essen das wetter ist
die absolute hölle
es hat den ganzen vormittag geregnet
aber ich habe mich schon geschworen dass
ich nach weihnachten auf jeden fall
urlaub nehme das muster nur bei meinem
chef einreichen der ich bin ich hoffe er
lässt mich frei machen
beide preise für mich nur noch ein
belogen
das nimmt angezündeten mitgebracht ich
habe auch nur überraschung für dich
nichts großes alter kann die
zurückbringen
die häuser wenn sie dir nicht gefallen
du musst dir nur angucken da hätte ich
mir kann solche aber so zur
weihnachtszeit ist doch gut so hörmann
die auch draußen aufstellen
ja aber ja doch also zur weihnachtszeit
kommt jemand einfach natürlich deine er
der ist süß oder das wusste ich dass er
dir gefällt damit dazwischen bleiben
oder wahrscheinlich auch ich habe auch
die ganze zeit gesagt ich weiß nicht ob
ich gerade für mich ausgesucht haben
oder einfach und ich wollte auch so voll
viel kaufen dann habe ich so richtig
gemerkt da habe ich natürlich gemerkt
wie teuer das die gefällt dir hammer ja
das habe ich auch gedacht aber nach 30
breakdowns sich gestern hat oder wie ist
es dir ergangen bei mir zu hause
es war
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
kaan mensch gewesen
direct media marketing ab und bot
perfekt und die beide im 1
macho mit limette
haben wir in barby christmann partie auf
da irgendwann es hat mich gelockt hat
hast du nicht nein und kelly ihr seid
beide vom gleichen schlag wisst ihr dass
ich bin ich hab schon zehn tage
geschafft oder neu zu dem zeitpunkt aber
du solltest 420 will ja was ist denn das
für ein vorhaben das ja so als ob du im
adventskalender ein türchen einfacher
schießt keuschheitsgürtel drittländer
holger da darfst du nicht so genau
ihr habt ja dafür schmeckt lecker oder
guck mal wie das aussieht ist das alles
an einen traum
[Musik]
oh mein gott das vegetarische oder das
sieht aber mit süßkartoffeln drauf und
eine suppe um mein gott lecker also das
hast du nicht was die da ist super brühe
ist auch nicht schmeckt hier wirklich
glaube ich habe mir diese liga ist so
richtig mild
richtig lecker das ist ja das ist aber
auch nicht ja und das ist kein scherz
wo ist denn diese da war doch mal diese
nur geschmack dabei
dann wurde noch mal gewechselt ja ich
meine auch dass er noch mal den kurs
[Musik]
ich habe die beschwerden sagte das ist
eine vegetarische rolle mit einem gemüse
drin
ich glaube ich dass jemand schaffen
würde
[Musik]
ich bin wieder kurzem kopf und ich habe
ich jetzt folgendes 14
wenn ihr auch mal wirklich ein
anstrengender tag also wir waren jetzt
gerade ganz lecker essen und sana
wir gehen jetzt in den rewe rein denn
wir brauchen jetzt zu haben sollen sogar
aktiv für das hat sie waren es auch
schon gelernt war naja und dann und dann
machen wir cocktails und dann mach mit
dran kitchen und dann mach mit rang arzt
also heute bitten besuchstag hey ich bin
sogar freddy kurz mal wieder zu sehen
wir mal was richtiges erfahren wollt
dann müsst ihr einfach mal auf die
wiener mit radeln wir gesehen das habe
ich aber das muss ich auch nur weil ich
mit einem block gesagt habe oder drauf
gefilmt ob ich höre gerade gemischtes
hacks und dem podcast und ich glaube 500
kommentare
[Musik]
gibt es den besten schokokuchen den hat
kelly gekauft werde
den muss man nur im ofen backen und dann
hat man so ein schuhladen kern extrem
lecker aviva drei konkret bedeutet wenn
wir den block also ich kann nur sagen es
ist für mich immer wieder dass es
trotzdem wenn ihr jetzt mal auf diese
seite die wir jetzt ein
wir haben ein kommt jetzt mal an gedreht
und haben uns alle ganz lieb und wir
müssen jetzt weiter trinken und wir
müssen wirklich trinken
ich hab schon ein bisschen einkleben
also schon jetzt geben sagt ja aber du
die andere aus diesem fast trinkt ja was
machen wir jetzt dran kitchen
ich habe schon 0,78 das thema wo sie ja
dass der generelle beat vonlanthen
kannst du schon mal zwischen messen
jetzt schon 0,81 new york 07 mein bruder
buddy sag ich da nur
fragen wir mal kelly die rasende
reporterin geht jetzt mal zu kelly wenn
ihr glaubt dass ich gerade versuche den
blog einfach länger zu strecken weil ich
heute den ganzen tag arbeiten musste
nein es ist nicht komisch dass wir
alkohol trinken unsere arbeit nennen
timo hat mir ein foto geschickt weil
meine blumen wieder geliefert wurden und
meinen so okay was muss ich jetzt machen
dann habe ich meine anweisung gegeben
mission accomplished krank das war auch
unser highlight bei rewe angucken
manfred manfred huck wir so lacht so
zwei stunden könnten wir noch mal ein
guck mal ich weiß nicht wir brauchen
jetzt vielleicht anderthalb stunden um
zu kochen
also wenn ich jetzt einen powernap macht
könnte es noch passieren aber es
hier sehen sie die junge kerl ihm ist es
wie locker seit sie 17 ist sie
erfolgreich auf youtube wir versuchen
mal näher heran zu gehen
hoffentlich erschreckt sie sich nicht
sie ist erschöpft
wie eine lba die challenge hier
einbringen oder so ich brauche irgendwas
was den alkohol puste gerät also
komplett hast du meinen letzten blog
irgendwie muss man ja die kohle
dezember kohl ablauf ohne das sieht aus
als ob du mir spülmittel gegeben es ist
ein leckeres da sind sogar blüten drin
wir treten gerade wirklich nur mit mir
drehen griffen arbeitsvorbereitung zu
sehen war stark gemacht
richtig da vor allem wie das in die
kamera auf das glas scharf stellt auch
mit diesem 1 das sieht so cool aus mit
netten leuten 2020 würdest du gerne
kochen damit zurück schreibt grüße gehen
raus endlich mal ja ich kann es mir gar
nichts sagen man eben mit ihm gerne den
handy mein teil machen henning hat
nämlich schon mal das ich geschrieben
mit kochen
herning kannst du bitte schreibt felix
felix felix blumer ich habe band es war
okay zu sitzen eure latte wieder und
natürlich darum hervor
naja stimmt das ist karola führt das ist
aber nur mit überraschung also die darf
dich nur überraschen
ja genau ich möchte wissen bin ich in
einem kampf sehen möchte apache und
felix ja das ist wie links und goliath
david gegen goliath apache gegen denkt
das ist der pott box kampf den wir
brauchen
apache gegen felix lob rechnen müssen
den beef anzetteln damit sie sich
prügeln
[Musik]
und wenn ich jetzt noch mehr aufnehmen
dann werde ich mich morgen schema sich
jetzt auf